el presidente de pedro ocasión no pudo
demostrar a los peruanos ninguna
justificación para sostener el toque que
a la medida había sido criticado por
diversos sectores del país que la
calificaron como inconstitucional la
protesta ciudadana que ha tomado las
principales calles del centro de lima lo
he hecho retroceder diversos economistas
sostienen que perú existen alrededor de
8 millones de personas que se dedican al
comercio informal y ellos hoy día no
pudieron salir a trabajar esto encendió
el rechazo popular entonces pedro casi
no comprendió que tenía que dar un paso
al costado y es así que abandona la
reunión del congreso de perú para
dirigirse al palacio de gobierno y
eliminar su polémico decreto supremo y
francisco como queda entonces
políticamente pedro castillo ante esta
derrota
pero que ha sido que hay una posición
vulnerable las marchas que continúan en
la protesta esta noche en el centro de
lima están pidiendo su renuncia porque
consideran que ha dejado al país en una
situación insostenible desde que asumió
el poder hace ocho meses por otro lado
sus opositores que en el parlamento
exigían la eliminación del toque de
queda que han empoderados como los
vencedores de esta jornada